The First Car Accident
Car accidents are a sad fact of life.
Every day thousands lose their lives in collisions,
crashes and accidents.
Though the car itself is a fairly recent invention,
the first recorded accident involving them
could have happened almost 300 years ago.
Depending on what your definition of a car
is.
Though it looked nothing like the modern cars
you see on the road today, the very first
accident involving an auto-mobile is said
to be one involving the creation of French
inventor, Nicolas-Joseph Cugnot in 1771.
Cugnot supposedly built the very first “self
propelled mechanical vehicle” capable of
carrying passengers.
We added that extra part at the end because
the first “car” (a word we use in the
loosest possible sense) was thought to have
been invented by Father Ferdinand Verbiest,
a Flemish missionary.
Of course, as is the way with every single
invention ever, Verbiest was in China when
he invented his toy, because China seemingly
invented everything, even toilet paper.
We’re not using the word toy in a chiding
manner either, Verbiest’s invention was
literally intended to be nothing more than
a toy for a Chinese emperor.
As such, the final creation (if it was ever
created at all) was far too small to accept
passengers; thus, Cugnot holds the title of
creating the first known auto-mobile that
you could ride in.
However, as noted in this Jalopnik article,
Leonardo da Vinci beat everyone to the punch
by two clear centuries in coming up with the
basic idea of powered transport.
But we digress, Cugnot’s, fardier à vapeur
(steam dray), is likely the very first built
and assembled steam powered vehicle in history
that could transport a human being, though
it never actually saw widespread use.
The story goes that some time in 1769 Cugnot
showed French officials his prototype design
for a steam wagon capable of carrying cannons
for the military; however, it wasn’t until
1771 that Cugnot had a working prototype people
could ride on.
Cugnot then reportedly invited several French
officials to join him on the maiden voyage.
During the trip, the vehicle careened out
of control and smashed into some unlucky person’s
garden wall at a nail-biting 2MPH.
However, some historians question whether
this event actually happened, due to scant
direct documented evidence.
To find a better documented accident, you
actually need to travel 98 years into the
future to 1869.
On August 31st in the City of Birr in Ireland,
Mary Ward, a scientist and writer had the
unfortunate privilege of becoming the first
known person to be killed by an auto-mobile.
On that day, Mary and three companions were
enjoying a trip on a steam powered carriage.
While in motion, the carriage hit a bump,
throwing Mary from her seat and into the path
of one of the carriage’s wheels where she
was crushed and instantly killed.
Mary’s death was reported the next day in
the King’s County Chronicle and a formal
inquest was held to discover the cause of
death and whether anyone was at fault.
In the end, the jury decided that Ward’s
death was nothing more than a terrible accident,
though the reason for the carriage suddenly
jolting and throwing Mary to the ground was
never discovered.
This murderous steam carriage itself was invented
by the pioneer of the steam turbine and Ward’s
cousin, Sir Charles Algernon Parsons and his
brother.
Remarkably, Parsons was only 15 in 1869, meaning
he invented one of the earliest precursors
to modern transport at an age when many of
us are just discovering girls.
Although, at 16, Alexander the Great was busy
conquering Maedi, when they dared revolt against
Macedonia; also, at 16, a peasant girl by
the name of Jeanne d’Arc, aka Joan of Arc,
was taking her first steps into historical
baddassedness by having the gall to approach
a garrison commander and trying to tell him
how to do his job, so take that Sir Parsons.
Parsons didn’t just invent the death mobile,
he and his brother were two of the passengers
on board the carriage when Mary was killed.
Luckily for the world, Parsons wasn’t deterred
from inventing by this terrible accident and
went on to contribute massively to the world
of engineering.
It would take until 1896 for the first fatal
accident to occur on English soil whereas
the first accident in the US occurred five
years earlier than this in 1891.
In the case of the former, the victim, Bridget
Driscoll, was struck and killed by an auto-mobile
going 4MPH.
If you’re wondering how Bridget was hit
by a raucous vehicle powered by explosions
and fire travelling slower than most people
walk, according to witnesses of the time,
Bridget saw the vehicle “zigzagging” towards
her and simply froze out of either fear or
utter confusion, which resulted in her being
unable to get out of the way.
As for the first accident to happen on American
soil, this was decidedly less dangerous and
ended with all parties leaving unharmed.
The event itself occurred in Ohio in 1891
and it involved auto-mobile legend, John William
Lambert.
The accident itself was the result of Lambert
hitting a tree root and swerving out of control…
If only he’d thought to invent power steering
first.
So, in the end, there are two possible stories
about the world’s first car accident, it’s
either, “A lady was horribly crushed in
front of her teenage cousin by the invention
he created in 1869“, or “A Frenchman smashed
into a large stationary object, a wall at
2 MPH in 1771 and walked away unharmed.”
We really wish there was more direct evidence
of the latter, because the first accident
ending in a death is decidedly less humorous.